[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
hello everyone thank you for joining us
for another session of st. Louis chess
club plays the people today we have our
grand master in residence Grand Master
Jessie cry he will be playing for the
Chess Club so and we are playing on
chess calm today Notley chess so join us
on chess calm search our name it's uh
who we were the social search thing was
chess club you'll find us and then sent
us challenge rated games only blitz time
control so game five do you play like
game game five three five game five four
three - sure yep
so blitz time control only radio game
zone we need no casual no participation
Awards here so there you see that that's
that's not the leak right is that the
link is that the leak what do you mean
exactly because that that's the link
link to lead to leach s right chest
ahold body
yeah problem well we have a we have a
little time here so let's let's give up
this shout out to our men in the back
Danny Machuca
yeah Danny before you put up the link so
he say it's not him there's another man
the bag name is I Isaac he was here with
us yesterday huh
put up the correct link man why don't we
why don't we just go ahead and start a
random random game I ran okay yeah let's
start let's our blip blitz game just to
get things going this game just to get
things going
that's five well Tony let me use this oh
I'm already started you let me use this
opportunity to ask you so you you were
doing Oh what happened to here boyo born
it what Oh buddy anyways see how long
have you been at the club time so I I've
been working for the color for about
I think just a little over four years
I'm getting a lot of people aborting me
here they're just like you know what I
think it's like and well it's a little
bit unfair what you guys are doing cuz
the rating says 998 so if I play you and
then you lose it's like god no that's
terrible
you know maybe that was it who was on
this account earlier playing 9 that was
that Isaac getting us a 998 rating it
sounds about right so high it's like
Isaac is the one in the back factor
right now he's uh he was the one that
got us out rating all right newer it's
the last time you didn't get a chance to
play it's showing challenges right now
chess calm so yeah there's the link
chess comp way so not not lishus chess
calm yeah here we go we're gonna play
some random random games here I'm
playing an Edwin from Mexico hey hello
Edwin he doesn't know that he's online
that's pretty that's pretty odd any of
these guys oh you're on laughing oh he's
playing good move so yeah so we are
starting with a radio basically right
under a thousand but if you want to
flake right message as you cry that's
what you have to do that's what you have
to do okay uh-huh
deal with it deal with it this is pretty
Edwin's got a pretty spicy position on
me already yeah I'm gonna castle because
I believe in development that's one of
the few things I believe in I don't
believe in much in his life well that's
an important one let's see where we talk
about what you're talking about you you
being at the club oh yeah okay so I've
been started up in here just a little
over four years I actually started out
in the Scholastic's department so I
dealt with a lot of kids schools parents
principals iran's classic tournaments
for the chess chess vote for a while now
finally transferring into marketing
department which is why i be part of why
I became co-host of this mm-hmm
but yep that's me pretty much in a
nutshell they're cool and also one of my
job's is to make distract you make sure
you know people get a fair chance here
[Music]
so well let's talk about where do you
hail from Jesse I grew up in Santa Fe
New Mexico
I have I'm kind of the only only like
you know chess player who made only GM
come out of New Mexico how about you
where you come from uh born in China
uh-huh lived in Chicago first for a
couple of years and then been in st.
Louis ever since like 2 mm I want to say
so it's been in a long time my last move
was probably superficial but we're gonna
blame that on you okay yeah I'm okay
with that I'm okay with that
what up and say what you did you go to
college in Chicago I did not actually
win the college in st. Louis so ya came
here in I want to say a phrase 7th or
8th grade one of those two and then
we've been here ever since
travel a little bit when in my early 20s
but were you part of the chest colleges
here st. Louis
no Iowa actually did not so the chests
let's see when we Chess Club started in
2009 mm-hmm and I graduated college in
2010 and then uh and I think like chess
scholarships and all that stuff didn't
really come here until years afterwards
so I wasn't a part of that but wish I
would have been maybe I mean I'm not
good enough to actually get a chess cop
[ __ ] but let's see how do you create a
challenge it's getting canceled since
you're already playing you can't be
challenged while playing uh oh I can't I
be challenged why I'm playing Danny
would you go what's the how do we bypass
that
well just keep on challenging us and
hopefully I'll get to you I guess until
we find this so better solution time for
that I'm definitely let's quit but this
way from this game here I just picked up
a random challenge but next time it'll
be from somebody in the audience yes
sure yes
so keep keep challenging us edwin from
mexico should probably resign but that's
okay
maybe sooo resign huh oh dang okay
alright so Romano challenged us ready
game blitz time control or even actually
do you do you play like poke a bullet
long uh you know yeah I grew up in an
era where that wasn't acceptable okay so
no bullet you know it's funny though now
it's part of the chess culture that the
strong players are challenging
themselves and bullet right yeah I mean
I feel like if you're gonna be a
professional chess player you should be
good in all-time controls really then
bullet why not like okay which one
should I accept here everyone's but
let's go dance
how about this guy yeah he's gotta go
woah he went oh no well they went away
what happened what happened challenges
what happened to the challenges chess
calm yes we are slow learner in chess
club chess calm we have it where our
challenges go you guys we saw your
challenges and then disappeared so
except yeah all right this is Ken from
Germany love it love it was his rating
there to what what 12 5050 okay we're
gaining room rating so we're we're happy
Jesse seems like a super nice guy he
actually he is a very nice guy um I was
actually talking to the executive
director Tony Richie yesterday I'm like
a dream yesterday's dream about how like
a lot of GM's are kind of kind of pot
kind of pompous not fun but you are not
you are definitely a really
guys stand up well today when you've
been beaten down really bad in life you
just kind of get humiliated you know
that is that humiliation comes from the
Latin word of being pushed into the
ground and that's you know when you had
enough of that you're gonna it's hard to
be pompous well how do we focus when you
got that going on up there you all right
this line has been seen a thousand times
this is a pretty good very seat now look
at this this is something interesting in
chess I think where you've got players
at you know a level of 1250 playing kind
of intense theoretical stuff now that
move I think that's a mistake maybe
maybe I'm the one missing it but
normally you don't want to do that but
if he just goes back to like d3 Nia I
don't think he wants to give me the
bishop whoa are you with me on this
maybe he's got a special trick here but
generally I don't think you want to give
me the bishop pair like that just
speaking but generally he's doing okay
and if you're watching you are not doing
well no he's doing fine good
let's just do that maybe maybe you know
what though maybe he's okay who plays
like 93 or something rejected so viewers
your challenge is to not get rejected we
were actually looking at the list of
challengers and then you guys suddenly
disappears oh I blundered hi blender
what I thought he was blundering with
Queen a3 and i blundered oh oh I
wondered and watching can if you watch
I've wondered bad buddy and he's got a
lot of time oh this isn't good this is
no boy no in fact I think I lose
everything hopefully he doesn't well
it's kind of hard to miss cuz I'm
threatening his clean out this is all
this is how your fault buddy that's part
of my job oh oh this is terrible I'm
just wrecked
Oh cry you lost you lost your business
you lost your lunch
you got a conk you got come back from
this one oh we're getting oohs and AHS
from the back room hey man all right
here we go I don't know what else to do
viewers I know it's hard to challenge
when it's only in real time so get your
stuff I am I am wrecked here buddy I am
just read to him fine though I am toast
he's got loads of time to you only up I
mean it's only he I lost a piece broke
only one piece and I think I'm probably
losing the exchange too I think
but I figure you can come back I don't
know if that rating is real or anything
well you can come back come back from
this I mean how often do you I'm sure
you how often do I get rekt I don't know
I'm sure you play a lot of games with
like people with these odds right no no
all right so let's count the damage here
I got a pawn for my troubles I got a
pawn for my troubles all right this is
truly and magnificently bad but maybe I
got a little bit of something-something
with Queen b6 at least he's gotta think
for a second D Machuca where I Isaac
viewers want to know why we can't switch
a light to lead us let me let me address
that one I kind of I I am so first of
all I'm so old that it's hard for me to
adjust to new technology no serious I
know I'm not making that up
and so I do some stuff on chess calm and
it's just a little easier for me to do
it you know is that a bad excuse maybe
but that is truly the reason we're doing
it today on on Chester come if it's a
really big deal I guess we could switch
but no it's not there you have it that's
why we're doing it all right now look we
were distracting him in that time and I
might be able to make a little bit of a
comeback here
see mo Muhammad we did not decline how
should we do this so basically alright
so there's about a 30 second gap between
what we say and what you see and on
those on your screens so kind of kind of
use you know calculate that into your
challenge we have not declined any
challenges so far we just see the list
and then people disappear so I don't
know if you're leading on your own or if
that's just a glitch I'm gonna say I
have practical compensation here let it
go with that that's my work that's good
in a compensation probably lessen out I
have an interesting choice here I could
play de to open the rook or just
casually play Queenie for work from
Woody is maybe he could play rook e1
check to the misérable king king c2 and
then I would need an out and since I
don't have that I'm gonna play like a
weenie and play here so right there's an
interesting position the claim is that
my two pawns plus the pressure on the
White King will give me hope to survive
definitely probably technically lost you
know I think you can do this thank you
for the coveted hmm
all right coming for me let's see what
do we got here so viewers let's talk
about what's coming up so Oh
Thanksgiving open for the same low
stress but some things give me a but one
of our biggest terminus of the year we
talked about this every pretty much
every stream but it happens from Friday
November 29th to Sunday December 1st you
we usually get about 112 between 125 250
people and we're capping this year 150
so make sure you pre-register the entry
fee the full entry fee is a hundred and
ten dollars however if you pre-register
before November 2nd it's only 80 bucks
so do that and the first and only for
our viewers on YouTube here the first
ten people to pre-register by 11 2 will
get a prize on the day of the first day
that things see me open I'll be there
personally to give you that price so
make sure you do it make sure you were
one of the first 10 all right let's see
what else so we have a couple big closed
tournaments coming up so we have our
winter classic November 9th starting we
will be doing commentary for a short
time with every day's around so you can
join us then basically around the same
time when we usually do our streams so
I'd be convenient for everybody okay
have a lot of top players and then
internationally we made a comeback video
but I knew you would damn they never
hold that oh come on
yes they do these people are evil
geniuses give me that guy and can you
just lost your edge what can we say can
you put up a good fight in that trick
with Queen a3 I was just totally I
wasn't paying attention and bam that's
how easy it lets game can be lost all
right so what's the status here why it's
definitely in trouble but it's not he's
got hopes you know if
manages to get a block a black squared
blockade he can make things a little bit
uncomfortable so let's say that it's
like so hypothetically if you were I
should have taken that pun what was they
doing go ahead so hypothetically if you
were playing against let's say a grand
man a grand master around your same
rating would you if you were playing
white would you win this do you think he
will win this game because if you were
playing this game where would a grand
man true master around your level will
be able hold this to it wrong
right now it's looking like it's toast
because he's got the g2 problem and I
got a rook coming to c8 and it's just
vicious look at that right now
a good rule of thumb here it's actually
coming into play is that should I put
this
opposites colored bishops are they have
a reputation as being a drawn situation
but in positions where they're still
pieces on the board like this one the
problem for black is going for white in
this case is going to be that I can
attack on the light squares and he
cannot right so the reason it's drawn
when the bishops are on is because
they'll be dark squares that I can't
pass through for example my pawn and f5
can't go forward however by the same
token if I plan the light squares he has
absolutely no defense as we're seeing
here all right so many moves to play
let's do with d8 like it I guess we got
some viewer comments here
practical compensation equals hopes of
luck BAM
this is no longer practical that is I
guess quickest ticket
okay how about judge Foley or do they go
away is the weird thing okay here we go
we got somebody all right so let's see
didn't my NIC my chest a common nickname
is doe doe echo phonos we got a cool
three-two from brazil okay
yeah well try to if you challenge us if
we if you're in that sweet timeslot of
challenges right when we finish the game
yes we will accept it we got Dan psycho
here from Hungary and I think this is
we've transposed into a kind of
theoretical line except white is up a
tempo so that's gonna be a problem
not lost I've had this kind of thing
before so it's not technically lost or
anything but definitely a bad news bear
situation dan dance ago so she he that
this guy actually challenges all the
time he's a con sisa regular here on our
stream so we'll see how he does I think
he's in a little trouble here trouble
already man trouble already
well Jesse uh tell us about your book I
I haven't had the pleasure of reading it
but I heard it's really good so thank
you do a little quote promo for us okay
let me just say I'm gonna talk about the
book but there I got h4s a move I've got
more mellow things like castles and
Queenie two on h4 I got to worry about
c5 that's think I'm trying to help you
fight it I never do my best
mmm this is a real spicy tomato here you
know what I'm gonna give you a shot here
dance ago c5 might just bust me open I
honestly I can't tell it feels to me
like h4 should win that's just my like
just general feeling that doesn't mean
it hope in that is my feeling I love him
when people do to do what they how they
feel the net the natural move it feels
right I'm gonna see it happen okay yeah
so actually people somebody on my stream
I just did this dream and mentioned that
they had read my book three times and I
was like wow you know it's interesting
phenomena I you know I wrote the book
years ago and like I just said on my
stream right I wrote it really for
people who aren't necessarily chess
players here's a nice one does white
those black want to take that thing I'm
just gonna actually I have two choices
here I could smack it but I could also
play other things like g4 it's a nice
position let's go for some bold moves
boom got you alright let's go for some
bold moves whack let's see yeess
somebody said 'hey six somebody says
greetings from sweden McCree oh thank
you for joining us i'm sweden nice thank
you very much good book
somebody says good book oh cool
now I think I got a trick here let's
just see how powerful this is snip oh we
got a trick coming anyway it's a very
rewarding when someone tells you you
know that they've read your book three
times and I worked really hard on that
story really hard and it was meant I was
I saying four more for people who didn't
play chess that was my intention anyway
she's just kind of give a window into
chess for people who you know might not
necessarily be players themselves and
for the most part though you know if I'm
gonna complain it's that I didn't get
that group right I didn't get I got what
I actually got was two chess players Hey
the book yeah
alright Aska you're you're not looking
too good man here all right one you can
give me a good night nice try nice try
nice try alright who else we got now
challenges now hopefully you get it in
Patrick Daly all right gonna playing
here we go looks like this is three
three two all right perfect
oh I wasn't even watching with you what
we're looking at this is now black
played e5 we could actually transpose
the system we just had but white would
be up a tempo on that one if that makes
sense to people
because I then have to play e3 e4
afterwards this boring thing that I'm
playing now is a system that Bobby
played a couple times and it's just so
boring a nice that I've taken up taking
it up
yes oh that's okay okay we're playing
for the full boring here just you know -
I don't like giving black his beautiful
normal Kings Indian business you know no
one wants that I don't want that I'm
gonna get out of Dodge
just drop the plan the GM looks like my
old geography Oh Oh
get back mr. Knight you know who you
remind me of when I first saw since all
you who is it the the actor that played
Robocop in the original oh and just see
Oh God yeah he was also I don't know if
he seemed like the start Star Trek
movies but like uh and he was cuz
robocopy you don't ever see the guy's
face right yes he was like yeah but like
like in other movies like you remind me
I was like huh like that's pretty cool
all right
what are your thoughts on the semi Abra
Bach system pretty highfalutin I would
say about that that's a highfalutin
system I think I'm doing okay here with
this III don't know I thought he
couldn't take that bond and we're gonna
find out if I'm right here oh so you
remember the guy you can that that you
you blundered a bit bishop yeah he's
writing he was like too excited when he
when you book Leonard the there's nothin
anything for the next two minutes thanks
for the game beginning beginning was
from a magnus carlsen game until the
ponder okay
oh no good to know so i'll say about
that's really interesting about the
magnus carlsen game is you know magnus
amongst first it was calm ski and then
who started playing the london and at
the time it seemed like maybe like a two
on
vicious way for white to play definitely
not old-school where you play d4 and c4
right but then when you look at how
Magnus plays against the Rui with you
know very slow and d3 and c3 it's the
same kind of style with a London right
you're playing for a very minimal edge
and so anyways a lot of people now
because people follow the world
champions are playing the London and
yeah oh I was mistake and there is yeah
you know a broad theory now with the
London was it developed answer you good
job nice try nice try
alright next one now the thing about me
and blitz is I will eventually blunder
that's just part of the deal here the
philosopher alright so you're up oh this
bow we got a serious contestant here
21:24 oh if I beat this guy his ratings
gonna plummet yep
that's what we want we want to gain gain
some points from the higher rated ones
look at this
Danny Machuca did this against me he did
this against me so we're gonna see if oh
okay all right let's just go BAM and see
what he likes it
I'm assuming Danny Danny law see you
what the I was black we were I know like
a fun practice game and he he said
something to the effect this is all
about the London actually that something
like Magnus doesn't like playing the
London anymore because of this Bishop f4
thing no I don't know if that's true but
that's just what Danny told me anyways
my intention is just to play wildly with
h4 h5
let's go nowheres correct they're not I
don't know I have to watch out for his
Knight g-force at some point I don't see
here so one of our regular viewers named
Chester calm named solitaire bad wants
to play you if you get your challenge in
when we're done with the game we'll play
you
[Music]
he's always coming for me boss oh oh
okay okay a little frightening for mrs.
whitening here we go let's see it so do
you do you teach much yeah
not as much as all some other people but
I do teach do you teach like like groups
were mainly one one on one um recently
it has evolved to be mostly like online
okay you know and I've got various
students who I'm teaching online this is
a very rich position these perk
positions in general really fun and
interesting and may I probably miss
played it in some way but I was just
doing following Machuca Slean
I got a nice time adventure like Knight
d5 is interesting he plays d5 that seems
to like cut his kind of self awful we
got people rooting for Philosopher's all
right I just gotta make sure you're
gonna lean doesn't get drowned out there
root against somebody who you know was
gonna lose get out of here where's my
comer is he in the building he is not he
is I don't think he's nothing so he'll
be and it's Wednesday no I don't think
he is but if you wanted to see Mike
every Friday 3:00 o'clock play the
people that's my school oh yeah so one
thing we mention about this is I thought
black play fine until the d5 d5 cut the
Queen's ability to come back and it kind
of invited my nighty now maybe I'm wrong
about that but you know this is all this
opening it's all about initiative right
who and who's got it and who doesn't
and so it feels like white now has the
initiative I could have played me for
there I guess
very difficult for black to castle
that's a bummer for ya it's good good
for us I like it I'm just gonna I just
want to take all that guys points
all the guys were any points skimmed oh
man yeah he's a philosopher philosopher
I don't I take a philosopher's points
I think he's toast unless I miss his own
Jersey so I I asked our resident campus
but it to let's say what are your
recommendations for let's say a kid who
isn't between like 1600 to 1800 or even
2,000 and they're like I want to be a GM
is there a certain something in the game
that you would focus on for like I hear
a lot of people say just focus on
tactics that's kind of where you get
that better at that right at that ring
range do you agree with that word do you
have some other views on this um well
I'm well known actually for being very
dogmatic on the point that people should
almost exclusively study their own games
hmm
and so that's been my my dogmatic
position for quite some time so I better
not change it but uh yeah so even with
kids I think the challenge is they need
to oh I need a good move here it feels
like I'm winning here but I need to
I need to finish it off you can do it
you can do it
nine eight seven just seems so weenie
that I don't really really want to play
wienie chess and I gotta be a little
careful that my queen doesn't get
decapitated back there no no we need
chess I believe our philosophy on the
show is go big or go home so do what do
a sec if you want to like it out let's
let's do it do a sack if I want to you
can sack if you want to oh all right I
really think you guys like you guys
can't hear this but we have some singing
coming on the back room as well we're
joining in they're joining in played me
please my username is H del della tour
from Spain cheers from Spain welcome
from Spain we will try to get to you so
you have to get in that suite time slot
where we just finished a game you have
to challenge us if your friends don't
pawn you can leave them behind all right
we got the car yeah yeah check to the
miserable Queen this is I think this is
painful phosphoryl we will take a
resignation at any point
give me some points yeah nice try what
is that like a hundred points I like it
I still accept solitary bet there you
know you alright I'm gonna switch it up
here yeah you know I have a PhD in
philosophy I did not know that out there
okay so that's why you have a soft soft
spot for the floss
oh I don't know what to do it means this
opening solitaire back now not so that
they're bought but sounds there's after
bat hold
what are the games you like playing
besides chess besides chest yeah that's
like my my main main thing no no I used
to be a big like video game mm-hmm I see
this is so I'm pretty old guy so don't
don't judge and it started with like
Starcraft uh-huh I think I made a small
error here actually he tricked ya trick
you can leave your friends behind that
was a sting to the rating yes it was sir
my other say this position is that black
plague c5 and he's fully equal because I
blew it I needed to play II forward sit
but it was a nice so is that typical
move order a six-string that's all your
fault really cuz I was talking to you
but yeah I'm just doing my job man but I
get any 7 I think that's a mistake
because now I get to play you for free
the bishop and now we're gonna talk
about Eva okay okay that's just my
understand all right
pushing me five there we go pushing push
you love it but my bishop however this
is actually an interesting difference my
bishop is not on d3 so that's a little
bit of a not a conundrum but it's
something in mind of these guys when we
raided for 14:47 oh you can use some
distractions come on yeah alright let's
see let's see um Starcraft come on nice
you legend I hope broodwar yep
play that Tony were you the guy that
killed us in league of legends to you no
I was not I was not I'm not actually
that great in that game when we played
that game for a short amount of time so
but you guys here's a fun fact Isaac in
the back is actually a big league of
Legends guy so we'll see if he can I say
what's your name on the wall
oh okay so we can't say say his name on
the air cuz it
this is skater to somewhat to everybody
including kids so we can't say his say
his name on air so it's bad alright what
up okay I'm gonna just ask a really
ignorant question
tell me about League of Legends what is
League of Legends so League of Legends
Isaac do you want to come on air and
talk about this come on yeah give me
Hannah pause everybody Hannah all right
I'm gonna give the microphone to him
there we go I talk so loud they can hear
me so well here comes mr. Isaac strong
why are we talking about League of
Legends on a chef's dream by the way
well because I was just asking about you
know different games that people were
playing mm-hmm and you know I am very
ignorant so of different games other
than chess so you know I'll ask the
question all right now here's an
interesting question should I take on e6
there's little ads without a doubt all
right all right so ya know how long you
been playing League of Legends I have
been playing since season three and
there's one season here and it's season
nine okay so as an adult this is
something you've been doing I picked it
up in college and we played in some some
college tournaments we beat Ohio State
holy moly
no how do you how do you feel about
somebody saying League is a terrible
game I played it for five years yeah
if you is terrible game why are you
playing the five years that's question
number one why why League has some very
high highs and some very low lows and it
gets really frustrating to have to rely
on random people it's a team game and
it's any imagined so it's five on five
you have a base they have a base you got
to go kill their base and if one of your
five just isn't kind of doing their job
and you expected them to do the normal
thing and then they don't well you can
get hung out to dry and it's just really
annoying what somebody just said finally
somebody interesting on there you
kidding me
audacity oh god that was funny yeah all
right let's see League is is a game that
used to be good but Sally isn't anymore
such a big change it's it's I think a
lot of it is also just people are not
bewildered anymore they've done it
they've played a few thousand of the
games and they climbed ever there's a
lot of people who can still keep getting
better and still keep climbing but at
some point when it's just you get you
get so disappointed when a teammate lets
you down like this game could have been
so easily won and I could have gotten to
the next rink but this person just
decided to leave the game or go make a
sandwich or something
so like the whole lead Leroy Jenkins
scenario yeah okay you punch it people
just Leroy Jenkins pretty hard don't
know how to just chill out and let me
only game for them somebody's somebody
says Isaac's a real pro nice you thanks
man are you are you a pro at it no this
is how we can reliably what's the
Jenkins Leroy Jenkins
you know from an old World of Warcraft
video where it's somebody so there's
there's a group of 10 people they're
strategizing they're about to go fight
this boss or go and go into this next
room and while they're in the middle of
okay you're gonna do that and you make
sure to have these buffs up and you pop
these spells at this time one person
just yells Leroy Jenkins and runs into
the room and just starts the fight and
it's just a awesome no and then the end
of the video says well darn it Leroy and
then Leroy's goes well at least I have
chicken because he is making chicken is
Isaac a pro that's me that's either Rex
or Roy drew from st. Louis they're
coming here a lot he's not a bro but no
he's pretty good don't oppress pretty
good
definitely not sucking up to hopefully
get a game Shh mmm falling off you hear
Louis arrow Isaac is giving league a
fair treatment
okay respect okay sorry game but it has
some serious tone don't
I think it would if there was any sort
of like single-player game mode in
league that I could just like de-stress
with sometimes I would play a lot more
of it but I can't just play game after
game with random people that I don't
know how they're gonna be I believe that
sometimes why people play for first
shooter game it's just you know yeah
boom a solid or yeah I can just go do my
thing and I don't like you can go play
cod and yeah you're on a team but don't
really care about your teammates all
right
saw their bat bar sorrow said Thank You
GM Jesse alright yeah you lost alright
now that my expertise has been shared
that was good I'm interested in people
playing different games stuff do I have
a trick here let's see if I get a drink
sometimes I tricked myself it's a
problem
yeah no I'm interesting that's you know
I'm I'm a chess fiend so I'm pretty
ignorant with other games but this this
particular game I think I'm winning this
one right boys
I think chess has certainly helped my
strategy and what other games it
certainly helped me especially with like
just evaluating which team is ahead
which team is looking to do this in
certain situations it's helped me out a
lot of that right
alright thank you so much let's see my
stream Oh actually one thing I want to
mention on this game is the people over
at leech s got me to do a video on the
advanced French it was something I kind
of had wanted to cut I guess you know I
they wanted me to do a video and they
said what do you want to do and I said I
want to do the advanced French from
whites perspective I didn't though I've
played it more from blacks perspective
and the interesting thing I wanted to
pursue really with it was the space
advantage
and because the space advantage to my
mind is like the big new Holy Grail
mm-hmm
for the chess world yeah so anyways I
have that coming out oh hey look at I've
led her to get oh wait maybe maybe I
have a way out maybe I got a way out
Jamie they're tricking me today I'll
tell cuz they are
let's why you're thinking about that
let's see here definitely blew it here
do you think in your opinion do you
think the slob where Carroll Khan is
better for black this love or caro-kann
they're they're very similar openings
right mm-hmm
what do you when you use the place black
uh well right now here I'm playing a
French even though I just blundered my
beautiful extra pawn and I came pretty
bad about it
um that was really upsetting actually it
happens it happens
c'est la vie Jesse roll with the punches
yeah I guess get them
tell me upon the pawn I didn't want to
give up is what it is so I'm actually
very interesting that in the fact that
you have a PhD in philosophy what I so I
have a friend who's studying philosophy
and he just explained to me how this is
your fault again by the way I know you
say that's a bad thing this is this is a
problem and for me it's my job to you do
this again so I'm happy
oh yeah so there's different areas of
study for phosphate right right what was
your at the denying I was really
interested in the philosophy and history
of science yeah so I always doing a lot
of historical work
in a lot of ways it was as much a
historical you know dissertation that I
did anything else I think I've freed
myself a little bit here
I think freedom has come to my people
you're doing you're doing fine I don't
know well now I'm doing fine before I
was not necessary it wasn't a bueno
situation I'll tell you I think there's
some trouble andand over here
tell me the distraction Chen that's a
good one I like that I like that dad
that describes me very well let's see
here Jessie what's your opinion on
people in tournaments who play games out
until checkmate even when clearly lost
well Patrick this applies to you buddy
[Laughter]
Wow Wow I forgive you here for that nice
try I did it it depends on the rating
honestly you know at the GM level it's
obviously it can be pretty rude but you
know the lower you go obviously the more
chance you're gonna actually have of
course right
so I don't know like for example when
I'm code I had been a while since I
coached really young kids but back in
the day you're playing some kid who's
got a rating of eight eight hundred
you're gonna play it Oh mate right he
played Oh mate I guess in that situation
because somebody would make a mistake
this is a good move Lee at the Rose
there's a bear oh she knows her stuff
dude dang a lot of these people are
really coming after me yeah only you
love under no man okay this is on this
is wrong here because if I play ninety
seven she's gotta be for alright let's
let's tempt her with that night over
there maybe she'll snippet
maybe she'll give me the snip of the dip
semen happen I think this is her
critical decision I believe that I've
looked at this and that white is better
so before can't be wrong but the weird
thing is and when if she takes then my
bishop gets to go to g7 so taking isn't
feels like it feels like the right move
but it's a little bit problematic
because now Bishop g7 is going to come
soon especially a lot of like when you
first start playing it's if you can
double up on us by taking a lot of
people usually most who usually do looks
good now that being said this is still
pretty hectic here
a four I don't think is right you know
let's just say I don't know just give a
word of advice to some people out there
what I'm seeing we're seeing on the
stream when you see it in other places
as well is that you've got some players
who are playing like some deep theory
against me some deep stuff she knew for
example that D takes e5 was a crushing
not a crushing but was a nice way to get
the advantage okay but the point I'm
making here is when that we've got these
players who are really competent at the
opening but then right then there's
problems later and in a way if that's
the case you probably shouldn't be
playing you should probably shouldn't be
studying the opening that much yeah
that's my two cents
so they didn't get into more tactics and
strategies where you're yeah you know
this yeah I think the reason people do
do openings is it feels empowered right
it feels like oh I feel like really
powerful when I play this move and you
know feels like I've got it going on one
of our viewers asked what is the deepest
question you have ever come across
during your philosophy studies this by
the way is trick is pretty standard and
I don't care about the bond right and I
just want to bring the bishop back any
the idea is that the unopposed
dark-squared bishop is gonna be too much
to handle in this position because I got
control of the center on the light
squares but I have blown it
I have blown this guy to thing before so
it's not especially the Blitz gave is
that over yeah now that was all me
deflecting from the question I don't
think there's one particular question
it'd be like what's the deepest chest
concept you've ever come across right
like I think I could give several that's
how I'm sure yeah right and similarly
with philosophy it depends a little bit
on just what I'm thinking about at the
moment I have it may be a slightly
different take oh well everybody has a
different take on philosophy I feel like
on some level we're all philosophers
whether we call ourselves that or not
because we're forced to deal all the
time with various questions and chess in
a lot of ways is just you know
kind of interesting
way to talk about questions in a
mathematical way I don't know if that
makes total sense what I see but yeah
it's a very fluid philosophical game
there's been a lot of philosophy players
who've played it now let's see oh
favorite question do I have a favorite
question you know that's hard - I do not
it's hard to say I mean it's hard to
think of um let me say that I'll throw
this out I think at the current moment
something that's bending my mind is the
idea that I guess it could be called
cosmological where we're modern physics
is at a weird moment right now where it
is failing in a lot of ways too
there's a lot of weird things it's
failing at like a lot of weird
projections that aren't coming through
the way it would it happen and so that
encourages weird questions like are we
in a simulation oh and I don't know if
that's that's definitely not my question
but what's interesting about that
question is we're starting to see when
questions like that pop up you got to be
like oh right the foundations of physics
are starting to be questioned right now
because the physics look so weird that
people can say that looks so weird that
it feels like we're in a simulation okay
right so you guys so that's like the
matrix thing kind of well the matrix is
an evil thing okay and the thing about
the matrix is the people that I play in
talk at the same time we got to make
people well you got I don't have what
what are the challenges go so the thing
about the matrix right is the people of
the matrix are actively oppressing us
whereas now one of the interesting
things is it looks more and more like
people don't give enough I don't give
enough of either way yeah people do you
want to play challenges what's going on
here if not where it's gonna star some
random game so we can put it up well
other Harrisons oh there's a real patch
we've played Patrick already Oh an ass
shot no my short I like it
well I guess I think that's gonna be our
mean oh yeah we're playing some playing
their meaning got to be careful over
there mean Ian's well this is somebody
asks wants to know what your favorite
spices cool favorite spice
just wait wait I wanted to experiment
with this and somebody asked how many
moves ahead do you usually calculate
while you know playing a blitz game just
by feel it's going by the natural moves
ladies and gentlemen natural moose how
do you recommend - how do you recommend
studying the middlegame
I think but I guess I would say like a
combination of classical games and
tactics and when you do the tactics
don't just do don't just play like the
chess calm you know tactics which is
fine you can do those but don't limit
yourself to those but also do deeper
things we're gonna set up a board for
example there's a great book called
perfect your chest by bola Keaton and
that book is a good example of just like
real world tactics and by the way like I
said before I really believe in going
over your own games and when you go over
your own games you will discover that
there was all kinds of tactics there you
and appreciate while they were going on
let's go
touch that night when you when you go
over your your games to you
I assume you use like a computer with an
engine to find out everything we're
doing at first no no I the computer
thing comes later if at all because I
don't have a computer when I'm oh oh my
god you let the God that was okay that
was a slip of thing I saw I saw a slip
of the finger if that show doesn't want
if he wants to give me that back I get
it man all right he I think I'm really
sorry like it was a crusher oh man slip
of the finger now he's got it he's got
he's got he's got you that was that
wasn't fun I got to admit it I just got
to play play more more Bowl all right
let's see
over yet is it oh definitely not I think
you can come back you definitely come
back from this come on come on cry Oh
buddy this is hot
let's see man that was a brutal
mouseland you know I haven't had that
many I you know I regret to say I've
played more Blitz than I should have but
I haven't made I don't think that many
mouths lips and that was just a that was
a pretty crucial one right now was that
was that was uh but it happens here from
time to time it happens yes he
definitely how he's they're saying you
definitely wanted to play Bishop g6 come
on guys oh hey you are going down again
BAM oh do it
now tell you what I still might not
necessarily be better but now I'm
definitely alive okay keep punching
keep punching somebody said table salt
it's got to be the best spice out there
[Laughter]
let me touch up on that so there's a big
so there's a big debate on whether salt
is actually a spice or not Oh
interesting cuz technically it's a it's
a flavor enhancer it doesn't have a
flavor the only it just brings out
flavors of other things more and I
myself actually is on agree with that
it's not a spice it's a flavor enhancer
but there are a lot of people do so you
know I'll give it to you on a
technicality I guess this game isn't
over my friends this one still has a
little bit of spice left in it somebody
said poison it's turning out to be a
poison bishop shoulda took it back so I
can get the exchange but
I don't want to rid myself of my
beautiful bishop but I don't know if I
have anything that's special otherwise
Oh
okay I don't want to do it
that's gonna take and you're gonna do oh
okay not entirely sure what's going on
here
well I shot looks like we're coming to
you all the pieces coming to your king
it's gonna happen I don't know I have no
idea
yeah okay I shut
I shot well that's let's talk to your
knight just a little bit no I do I know
what's going on I really don't now he
fart probably feels robbed just as I
felt robbed so you know comes around
goes around
we gotta be fair so yeah everybody's got
I feel the same thing done yeah do a
plan attack at this point we're just
doing what do I have what do you have a
plan of attack at this point I'm just
doing what I want to give it a grief I
want to give it yes yes I think I'm
blowing it no no shots Kings a bit
claustrophobic yep
nope I'm gonna attack that King all it's
just not going to be is a good move here
good move
yeah okay crying you need to play well
we're at our rating is 1462 so we've
gained 460 what do we start with
I guess 470 points in the past hour
that's pretty pretty cool c1 get to 2000
2001 I show it's kind of taking it to me
here it's not very friendly you hear
that you should be a friendly in life go
ahead and hit the resonation button
being friendly is all that matters in
life this is hot I don't know what's
happening it's gonna get real hot here
because it's five minutes so there's no
delay no delay my friends and it's hot
the question is Kenny I think he's going
for a night he's going for this end game
unfortunately
for the hood if we're talking about
endgame you know who has more experience
and study more I go with the GM do it
take him down
so the issue of course is I'm down upon
but it looks like unless he wants to
gamble I'm gonna get the rook on the
seventh no he gambled by somehow keeping
the Queen but that's it's not gonna do
that
you know this mouse I'm gonna switch
this mouse out you know what that was a
mount I had my own it's all because I
passed that's true he's this live on
that
why can you double why couldn't you
double the rooks on the H file and
threaten check me by on the back ring
with the pawn taking away on f7 square
is there something obvious I fail to see
interesting question I don't know I'm
actually not exactly sure what he's
referring to but it's not that I doubt
it
check check
oh man I gotta be some real tricky
little night maneuvers here yeah you
know let you concentrate so we can win
this game if I win this game I'm getting
a high five second times time advantage
she's got loads of different tries yeah
I like that one check to the misérable
king we going pawn grabbing there we go
love it wants the trade but okay I need
a pawn
yeah what's up with man ho buddy this is
gonna be hot I shot your we gonna have I
don't know I don't know this I'm
actually really unclear what's going on
here
oh okay taking it we're gonna go after
that guy well while GM cry is
concentrating let's make sure whoo this
is a tough we have a couple we have
classes tonight that are going to be
streaming also makes there's a link on
the chat our national master Caleb Denby
is going to be teaching a class road to
2000 if you want to try to get to 2,000
oh it looks like ooh
Shana gets a 2008 sure you watch it man
I don't know what to do this is a tight
Wow I got a nice Wow I got an idea
watch this one watch this one oh yeah we
have watch this one
antosha yeah we got this it was good oh
my god I like it
15:16 now now hold on oh you thought he
should have given me a take back is that
what you were arguing for yeah I was
like you gotta be be nice you know be
nice no I think the take-back thing
though I don't I don't blame him for
that yeah I agree
oh but that was hot
I was sealing with big bait seven I
thought over here I'm one I've won the
game we're gonna talk you know know
wasn't so easy Mouse slip that's like
all right question for you when it what
was a what is the last competitive
tournament you played in how did it go
I went terribly I had really the worst
tournament in recent memory I had played
this thing called the cherry blossom was
a nine round thing as an old guy it's
very hard to play nine rounds and I lost
several games I definitely the worst
event in recent memory so it was
terrible hmm and you know one thing that
I've already said right as I believe
that going over your games is the way to
improve and that is tournament was a
really good example of me
procrastinating on that promise to
myself because it was so painful such a
painful loss that I really was
psychologically unable like deal with my
terrible defeat you know I was just I
mean I couldn't
so but I am doing it now I'm going over
the games and this was in June that I
played the thing I guess I played an
action event that I won since then but I
don't I guess I don't count that you
know okay I'm hoping I hope Tony rich is
listening out there I'm hoping that they
invite me to come play something like
the Fall Classic
last year I was doing commentary for
that thing that would be classic well
viewers two things one it looks like
some of you are asking can you guys go
over at games from the grand swiss
tournament if you want to make
suggestions please email info at satan
with chess club or i'm gonna put it in
the chat right now also if you want to
help Jesse out and try to convince
everybody here to put them in a Fall
Classic also email if I'm still waiting
for one person to do it just email info
similar I thought that work and let us
know how you wanted what you want they
just want to type it into the box what
they want their power the people they
don't have the power
what do you think that this is America
you want everything now come on
yeah right just write write that write
those words and then to influencing the
scope that work in the chat and then
boom well we'll make it happen won't
make it happen see people think that I
have a lot of power to they can put in
the chat I can do to it but like I don't
I have people I answer to so you I have
to have a piece of paper to go to them
and be like boom people want this make
it happen
so you have to write it in you have to
write it in
that's rough forget people you get
answer yeah man that's the way you said
it I was like oh man that's rough I mean
I I'm at the bottom of the pyramid like
it's there's so many of you have a
Institute like you know so our man in in
the back Dan name of Machuca and Isaac
Idol listen to them if they tell me to
do something I had to do it on air you
know it's just one of those things yeah
I think this one looks good
see you are his kings oh man okay you
told another rough over there can you
start with correspondence streams here
on YouTube we're not gonna so hooks
we're not gonna properly never play
correspondence on YouTube that's just
ridiculous
oh are you saying something Diana you
want to they're talking about League of
Legends or whatever it is in there
League of Legends okay alright looks
like somebody wrote press 1 if you want
to have Jesse to plaintiff all classic
bro invoice hey Lewis Jeff stuff that
will work how many time to say it write
it in there you we won we won
bouncy monism yeah look who we just
walked in it's a no wait Ben Simon's in
here he wants to say hi he wants to say
hi did you know that Ben C Mon is a
professional wrestler commentator oh yes
I do know that we actually talked talked
about that on one of the streams
Saturday night st. Louis if you ever in
here coming back he's coming back coming
back oh oh here comes Ben Simon joining
us commentary commentary Tator
extraordinaire you know I was upstairs
preparing for Caleb's lecture and I saw
that there was a stream going I didn't
realize you guys were still on the air
horse no this is fine just be off by
5:45 so Caleb can go on and everybody
thanks for watch we were just talking
about that what's gonna do at 5:45 he is
going to be talking about trading making
exchanges work for you I think it's what
he said his topic I was gonna be about
so very valuable lesson all right I'm
out of here guys good luck alright now
one of the disappointing thanks to me
about Bensimon is he works in
professional wrestling but he himself
doesn't have a professional in wrestling
mate correct correct you know and I'm
like wow
I don't get it yeah we're trying to find
Nick mouseka you don't have a name like
the Terminator or the the death man or
whatever it is you want so I mean I
assume you you have a name you picked
out for him he was so you know angry
about it I was like dude you know so I
was um
I think I became what was i el gringo or
something like that I don't know I was
something that was last year we were
doing the Fall Classic and I found out
about that and we're definitely and
we're gonna start actually why don't you
guys start giving some names for Ben
Simon you guys just saw him like.he look
what he looks like you guys have a place
and they move on how he looks where what
your imagination you know wherever it
takes you
here's a question for you oh let's see
can you start
is it sure that cry considered the
French when when were variation a
mistake funny that's funny that we're
talking about it now to be okay so years
ago I was talking to my friend Alexander
Shabalin and you know shabal off who's
himself played 92 as well as Knight c3
you know anyways at the time said
something the effect of yeah it's a it's
a mistake it's gotta be because
obviously Knight c3 is more active
active and in the meantime since I did
that lecture ages ago I have had you
know I played the French myself and I
have had my own difficulties against the
dreaded ninety-two business and so even
in this game I played three c5 which one
of the advantages of Knight d2 is if you
get a French player to play three c5 I
think in general they're a little bit
too satisfied they want I'll speak for
myself I want you know that structure
with
and so three knight f6 is kind of like
the move that I want to play but after
three Knight of six maybe why does have
an advantage there maybe so g3 it's
getting spicy okay
bar sorrow will you have a second chance
yeah challenges you never know a lot of
people is just challenge and leave so
there's a very good chance you might get
a second chance challenges he's trying
to do some fancy business I don't know
Oh looks like we it was a suggestion for
Ben Simon's nickname death man
okay that's man holy that's a--that's
sound sound scary it does sound scary
I'm not sure if that fits been Finn's
assignment he's well that's his problem
you know he's out there doing
professional wrestling he needs to be a
little meaner right yes that's right
yeah lon Ben C Mon now I guess I can be
violent here or just like the normal
human being we don't do normal here go
over violent don't go big all right
let's see if this works out whoa okay
cool I don't know if that's cool but I
did it doesn't make me proud
words that everybody has used at least
once all right here we go pawn takes and
so I'm just trying not to - Mouse lip
over here the idea is that we're going
to play queen c6 and get some kind of
grief against the king that's the
intention anyway looks yeah it looks
like it should be you possible it
perfect nothing else and if f3 well I
can take on f3 as well as a rupee for
and so okay so there he goes that I
think he loses the Queen we're gonna say
oh yeah looks like it looks like it
don't know no Knight g4 might be mate so
we got a check do we have to check I'm a
little lazy right you don't want to
check it's bliss we don't have time to
check let's see here a second name
suggestion and brutalizer okay okay
that's pretty good it's the peace
sacrifice line in the classical French
sound I don't know there's a lot of
different
peace acts in the French so I don't know
exactly which one you mean yeah yeah
Damon Matt Damon Damon Matt clarify for
that clarify us on your question and
we'll answer back so it looks like Oh
we'll give you a hand for the lot last
opponent you just beat nice nice try
nice try we're up to let's crack 15 60
50 is 1,600 here right
oh yeah we're a fifties thing that
that's not like definitely oh well let
me tell you guys a story so you know
here at the club we've got all kinds of
people working there's people who are
chess players some not chess players and
anyways we got people working the front
desk most of them a little bit apathetic
honestly about chess in my view sure but
we got a girl up there named Alison
she's supposed to be challenging me by
the way
and she started when she started working
she was 1,000 and when she's sitting up
there at the front desk though she's
playing lifts all the time at all the
time slowly all the time so she is now
up as I understand it to to almost 1600
which we at the st. Louis chess club are
also almost at and that's gonna be her
big goal wait did you say she was
supposed to play you like now challenger
she was supposed to yes she was not she
wasn't supposed to be checking it out
like I think all right that's it I'm
gonna call call the front front front
desk right now and we're gonna make sure
to challenge have her challenging you so
give you guys some perspective we're in
the basement of the Cygnus chest that's
where our production studio is I'm gonna
call upstairs to the front that's the
main floor and have Allison chat and
Alice didn't challenge in there we go
this is I think this is a pretty
interesting position here not really
sure what's going on
all right let's see if she Alison come
on let's play anyways I just thought of
her because we're getting up to 16 this
is Tony Chen and I know that's her
business
Jessie cry and I are on the stream right
now we're calling in so Alison is
supposed to challenge us challenged
Jessie online we're just making sure
that happens did she play around there
so Alison is supposed to be challenging
Jessie on chess calm during our stream
which is now which is and we're actually
on the stream I'm calling you while
we're streaming or is winning if she's
Jesus around and she wants to if she
wants a challenge because Jesse is
saying she shouldn't chicken out so I
just want to make sure that happens
[Music]
okay perfect cuz we have 15 wait woods
named Lama Lord
okay that's fine
yeah I have a challenge well I'm a lord
I'm scared alright and there you have it
she is coming on soon and I made it
happen
made it happen what is this God we got a
kind of a spicy situation here with a
spicy end game for sure like I don't
know exactly what's gonna happen okay
that makes my weapon not necessarily I'm
better but at least makes my life a
little clearer I got a call from Grand
Master version Anna Cobian he is the
teacher for our select chess program for
the higher level rated kids and that's
supposed to happen tonight make sure
wonder if anything had happened hold on
hold on let me see
I want to do that class if he's out I'm
in
all right perfect how are you doing
winning yes you cook
I got a pawn oh man they they're trying
to do like some fancy business over here
look at that I'm just gonna develop and
pretend I don't see anything so in in a
high-level game when you play when
you're up a pond do you usually just
think like okay I have a pretty good
shot out of winning or typically is it
always a lot of withdraw draws spawns
aren't people on certain people yeah
that's that's a sad and sad yeah let's
see it uh basement dwellers yes we are
basement dollars dwellers correct but
we're definitely basement dwellers all
right so you remember how somebody
talked about the peace sacrifice line in
the classical French right he clarified
by saying the one that you played
against camps key question is camp ski
that's that's amazing that he know the
answer the short answer is no I don't
think it's but but it's really a very
interesting line for sure can I actually
if I let's say this game's over
can I like show a variation can I turn
on an analysis I think so Dan Danny your
thoughts we're okay right yes we can
okay yeah maybe after the game I can
just show what we're talking about this
is a very interesting position yeah yes
you guys just just saw
I have zero power I have to ask people
when all right somebody said a pawn is
like a queen - at GM people people pause
aren't people a cry looks like the old
man from up that's that's hard okay let
me just show briefly with something
briefly here because it is an interest
or not we're not gonna accept challenges
unless is from LA milord which I don't
see it okay so let's look at this thing
now by the way this is a little bit
do with computer analysis because this
was ages ago that I played it and it'll
be interesting to see what you know
stockfish now would think of the thing
so anyways this is the classical and now
the problem for white in this position
is there's loads of different variations
right
you were you were playing black I was
flying black so yeah we can flip it and
I believe it went like this Queen B six
nine a for Queen a 5c three takes b4
Knight takes pawn takes Bishop takes
Bishop d2 and it's a very interesting
position in the old way to play it I'll
just put that on the board is b6 and the
intention is that at some point we're
going to play Knight c5 and tell the guy
that he's got a recapture and we'll have
this like juggernaut a central pawns
gotcha Tomsky wasted me okay that gave
us two thousand five that was Maurice
Ashley his big HP international
tournament back in the day was like the
first big money tournament in the United
States for a while anyway
gosh so that led me to lose confidence
in the opening but you know a lot of
this stuff the the computer evaluation I
can imagine and changing on that one you
know it's a really yeah interesting
thing okay I'm ready for I'm ready for
challenge all right challenges but let's
say let's do a lot lock up come on
Allison you choose yeah where's that
you're chickening out here I see a lot
more Lord is that sure we don't see it
what's the challenge Allah milord oh I
want it to play Knight c3 Bay
oh yeah it was up for a little bit okay
what was the next one I'm gonna I'm
we're gonna make sure Lama Laura gets in
next time yep
keep keep at it keep at it Allison we're
gonna get to you
all right here we go
so as you see the people in the back are
playing something first of all all I
asked was I want to shoot beams out of
my hands and you put that up what is
that about
oh I want that I want to give me give me
something that's fire in my hands quick
with some flames land is cold put some
flames there come on that's good this is
why they're the B group B group flames
go keep some flame dang it dang it no
flames for you how dare you guys how
dare you all right I think I have the
advantage here because the night on B 6
isn't working
oh so Allison's in the chat right now
she says it says she has to play more
games before I can play a title player
no that's that's not what you promised
him you said it you were gonna play
you're gonna play come on the and so nm
llama Lord is the account of our
national master Caleb Denby who was a
staff member here
I don't think Allison has a chest calm
account so she's playing on her somebody
else's name but Caleb Denby I challenge
you like three times big dummy
do it again keep doing it keep
challenging us keep challenging us yeah
we're gonna get you the next time we're
gonna get to the next time
oh this looks evil here man oh look at
that
BAM if it's all London Bridge is falling
down and stuff yeah
Oh y'all need to close it down
I hate you guys by the way oh come on
you suppose it'd give me flames ready
for tomorrow give me some yeah give me
give me a let me like a charged up like
a Super Saiyan kid give me that thing if
you could have like some kind of app to
give me like gold golden hair
I want that'll be awesome - all right
awesome keep keep coming keep counting
us
I predict Jesse's gonna win this game in
about let's say like three minutes no
it's good you guys
less than three minutes okay we're
calling out now less than three minutes
we're gonna win this game so that's when
you get it get in there all right all
right we won all right let's see if we
can llama Lord let's do this Alison come
on
we're I'm only accepting lonely
accepting along with accepting Longhorns
see I think she's she's not ready shall
we call it to the front front desk again
where you had so anyways let me tell
this oh we're look at that we're over
1600 and so she let me just say like
she's working now she's literally
playing blitz all the time at the front
desk and so you imagine one thousand to
six to 1500 that's a huge game like
that's monstrous points and really I
think she's got that just playing blitz
you know Nakamura style that's how
Nakamura got good was just playing blitz
which goes against all wisdom it's the
world that you can get good playing
blitz but that's what she's doing over
there
don't do that the philosopher x.now
philosopher maan okay we're waiting for
the llama llama Laurel Alison what are
you doing what he says yeah Alison says
don't do that what do you mean don't do
that brazen Bishop is trying to play to
my lord the I'll give you 10 more
seconds llama Lord get in here then we
got take somebody else
I'm a time left man oh man oh man so if
you don't yeah Allison if you don't
challenge us I'm gonna make me make fun
are you upstairs when we're done with
this we're just playing
we're just playing a blitz game here
Allison it's not like you're on the spot
or something
Allison kid no what do you mean whose
bow all right let's go with somebody
else
screw it no she has a moment cuz
everybody got the skull or there ya go
go oh here we go
oh man the llama Lord oh man now she has
to defend this is Caleb Denby so she has
to defend Caleb dembe's rating right yep
yep we'll aboard in 20 seconds she's
sitting up there they're probably gonna
help her upstairs Ethan I'm sure I'm
sure but if they she doesn't play then
that's a bad thing that's not a good
thing if she doesn't play I think
there's a probably the last game to
right I think so yeah
I think so now are you gonna be with I
think we're doing this again tomorrow
you're gonna be with me again tomorrow I
will be here tomorrow correct it will be
here tomorrow I'm alerts coming at me
cool yeah so if you didn't get a chance
today we can play tomorrow yep Oh what
do you mean just pointing people we are
playing that Allison's one of the people
you can't just say she's not the people
just because she works here if you if
you don't we we just talked about
tomorrow
you also get another chance 3:00 p.m.
local time play a grandmaster cry again
it's pronounced cry that's some somebody
actually asked that mmm sure
Dada oh this is getting exciting what do
I do now let's see Tony is dyslexic cool
thank you alright can't breathe
sometimes can't read that's true thank
you GM Jessie thank you
it's been fun I think Lama Lord's gonna
feel the pain of the bishop I'm really
curious of who's actually I wonder if
Alison's actually playing where she's
God she loves to play she honestly it's
it's really you know one of the weird
things about the club honestly is that a
lot of the staff don't play it's kind of
you know as someone like myself who's
just a chess fan it's kind of sad
honestly but so it's you know one reason
I wanted to shout out doors like yeah I
think it's great it's great that
someone's playing and you know
potentially using the resources of the
club because the club people can get
like GM lessons and stuff and I can
improve and I would like to see like
more I have few complaints with this st.
Louis chess club so don't take this as a
grape but I would like to see more
players who let's say are whether
they're young or old who want to improve
and then they just come to the club and
you know come with the intention of
being like alright I'll work at the club
and I will improve right that's good I
got jumped it seems like you know
seems like it should be a cool thing
there's a couple people that do that
exactly that but yeah I agree with you
some more people should question for you
is your last name of Dutch origin yes
and by the way llama Lord I think she's
doing alright buddy
yeah I think you know yeah I think she's
doing okay let's put a little pressure
over there now she can throw in Bishop
h6 on me and at least she's gonna go to
an endgame
no I wasn't expecting that but maybe she
can get away with that all right another
question for you an 1800 player asks how
can I improve calculation and
understanding / devaluation of the
results of the resulting position oh I
won a piece against Lama Lord but how
can I improve calculation
I think the tactics trainer is good and
I'm gonna again plug going over your own
games because the thing about it about
calculation is you can't see everything
so part of going over your own games is
just coming to the realization that you
can't it's absolutely impossible and so
there's gonna be some things that it is
possible to see and other things you
should not even get mad at yourself for
missing if that makes sense right
there's just some things that you will
not see and that's part of the game but
there are other things you need to whip
yourself over and be like oh dude I
hadn't seen that right and it'll be
funny cuz woah funny is the right word
but there'll be a lot of times when
you're playing where
you'll have thought about the position
quite a long time and then after the
game you'll find a tactic and it's in
those moments I think where you can be
like oh right I I can find the resources
that were there where I gave up looking
during the game you know and the
resources in fact were there so that's
my that's my couple cents God yeah ok
let's say tenets uh Jacob you will
you'll kill to get to be close to such
an active awesome Club thank you we are
pretty awesome all your people all the
people in your club are old and don't
want to get better anymore
wow that kind of sucks
we are always about improvement here so
if you ever want to stop by it'll be fun
alright stop by one of our big
tournament dates you should play a lot
of games a lot of good people let's see
somebody said that this is actually Kate
Caleb you're playing is that what you
mean I think this is Caleb's handle yeah
it's not but Alison I think usually
plays on leeches so correct Caleb had to
give over sacrifice is for the benefit
of all
Caleb sacrificed is rating so we get
this incredible match going on here is
an upstairs Downstairs Scituate that's
right that's right so it was like
somebody said Alison you blundered well
she did blunder so you did blender it
happens in life every blade blunders one
thing actually with Alison's be aim that
I think is very common throughout the
chest world now first of all a lot of
people are playing chess simply as an
online thing ie they've never played any
other kind of chess right they've just
played online
and what I can see with Allison is she's
learned a little bit of tactics and it's
yet to get a positional sense of how
things work and so I think one of the
cool things about you know if she took
some time to like she can get lessons
with masters and GM's Yatta Yatta here
is to work a little bit on her
positional understanding cuz when you
play too much blitz you're just gonna be
focusing in on the cheap tricks correct
right all right and it's fine to play
four tricks with your playing glitz but
you know you want to move beyond that
even in blitz to get to be more
dangerous as you can see I hung a piece
and it's you know it's possible to win
that way but for her improvement right
that's the next level all right good job
good job
we are out of time so that was the last
game just Dani real quick when is a
lady's way tomorrow so yeah so we have
we have a new show tomorrow so tomorrow
we continue with our GM place to people
and we have Alison coming so guys ladies
and gentlemen this is Alison she was
playing upstairs under the handle Allah
my lord she will be playing tomorrow
actually on a stream starting at 4:30
ladies play the people right after
actually in place of people all right so
if you want to play her tomorrow join in
at 4:30 and see how you can do all right
well thank you very much for joining us
we will see you tomorrow 3:00 p.m. sharp
all right
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club